from the man who helmed the resident
evil franchise
and the star of the resident evil
franchise comes another
capcom adaptation apparently
they're capcom's trusted duo sure why
not they made the resident evil films
over a billion dollars worldwide and
that's a sign of
good filmmaking we're gonna watch
monster hunter trailer today
i'm excited that tony jaws in it though
i'm a big fan of his
i've seen four of his movies you know
that qualifies as a big fan right there
especially in my book
captain do you have any idea what those
markers
awful dialogue cut definitely bravo team
they don't just disappear
where the hell are we
this looks like kong skull island
just hey
yeah king kong lived in the desert
instead
cool
this is officially above my playground
[Music]
i feel like vin diesel should be in this
movie
yeah that's that's one option
oh
[Applause]
dragon heart yeah it's also a
playstation commercial
at the same time cool all right
so i haven't played the game i'm aware
of the game it's been around since ps2
i've of course
heard of people talk about the game and
i've seen certain images from it
so in no way and i'm sure have you
played the game i don't think you played
the game
no i played nightmare creatures on
nintendo okay
yeah as far as uh this discussion of the
trailer will go it'll be just
only off of what the footage is giving
us
and not really in comparison to the game
be curious leave your thoughts down
below if you have played
said video game now uh when watching
this it seemed like it was borrowing
from
a lot of movies we've seen before it had
the paul
ws anderson desert resident evil vibe
already i mean mia djokovic seems like
they just plucked her right out of there
and put alice over here
that's what her character feels like
early on i was getting kong skull island
vibes and then as
the trailer kept progressing it just
kept feeling
more and more like kong skull island the
action looks fun looks cool i feel like
this is lacking self-awareness because
this is such like a cliche
everything about this looks very cliche
i felt like you could have put vin
diesel if this star mia djokovic had
been diesel i would be more excited
about it
because this looks like the kind of
movies that vin diesel would also
star in yeah i could elevate with his
earnest
sense of commitment into personality uh
but yeah i agree this this doesn't
really even look like it has a plot
based on this trailer it looks like they
get lost you know in whatever this
otherworldly creature portal is
and then you know basically have to just
fight and survive which is fine
but this really is probably like a
chosen one or something to communicate
with the monsters looks like your team's
going to be getting
killed off one by one yeah it takes one
giant monster to kill up one american
soldier
step on another guy step on the third
guy and you're good
it looks like she arcs into freaking
furiosa
yeah you know and then she'll get cast
as furious aunt in the prequel that's
coming out pretty easy
and then it also kind of had like some
pacific rim vibes
some of parts of the trailers also look
like a transformers movie especially the
desert shots in the michael bay movies
and they're popping out of the sand
yeah exactly exactly that was my first
touchstone and yeah it felt like if you
took that
setting and you mix it with the kaiju
from pacific rim and then you took the
characters
this is the movie you're gonna get yeah
which is fine i mean
i i don't know at this moment because
again not having any real sense of like
a plot
in the trailer does kind of hurt this
for me because i'm like yeah there's a
bunch of cool looking monster fights and
stuff but like the
the badassness is hurt by the fact that
i don't know if they're gonna even
attempt to make me care about anything
other than seeing cool action and and
it's funny to me because paul doesn't
pods of us anderson
of course that's all it's going to be
he's made you know
he made that movie i don't know what why
he stayed
on verizon he made mortal kombat i don't
know why he's the video game
helmer i don't know either he doesn't
even faith
i i bet as someone who hasn't even
played the game
that this is very loosely based
on the actual game but i can definitely
see this being the kind of thing where
it's like why don't we take the general
theme and plop it down into now
you have like the us military you know
take come on yeah
which is fine um but yeah i don't know i
can't escape this feeling like i don't
know how paul w s anderson gets these
movies
made because this more than any of his
other at least trailers struck me as
like the kind of thing you'd see for
something that's going straight to video
he
gets these like amazing budgets to do
these things that you know they always
turn out the same
way i always hear the same things about
them they must just do really well at
the box office or something because
i wouldn't have guessed until i saw his
uh his name card in there shocks me that
capcom
seems to trust him i don't know the
behind the scenes but come on he did the
resident evil movies and now he's doing
this is one of capcom's biggest games
for them to
hand it off to him i don't know they
must they most like what he turns out
from from the movies because right now
i'm like yeah the visuals look cool
the thing that can deter me from certain
ones of paul w s
anderson films is that occasionally they
can be like so bad it's fun
sometimes it's just like okay they're
taking itself way too seriously but when
there is action it's really cool and
this looks like that kind of movie that
i'm probably gonna find all the
dialogue driven scenes to be either dull
or laughable
and then yeah and then uh the action
will probably be
cool the action looks competently
directed though
i'll give it that doesn't look like it's
relying heavily on a bunch of like crazy
handheld stuff like that the action look
very clear
and to capture these monsters in broad
daylight
is usually in in films you know to
capture monsters
you gotta it's like it's broad daylight
and it's in the desert yeah
the coverage there's no shadows to mask
it
to make it blend in with the darker
environment so for that department it's
pretty impressive
of when you're looking at it i mean it
still looks like cgi but it's cool to
look at regardless
the costume design looks cool i am
waiting for the day
tony jaw can be in an american film
where he really
demonstrates what made him so cool in
thailand you know
okay he's going to fight a monster in
this handful one-on-one oh
why this is the kind of like he did
triple x and this you know furious like
now he's gonna do turok i've seen the
hongbach movies i've seen uh the first
protector movie so
i'm familiar with some of his actual
movies and i keep
waiting for him to like when is he going
to be in an american movie
that represents that side of tony josh
not this this is like the kind of stuff
jackie chan went down later in his
career
he should be doing the cool stuff right
rolls that scream we've got an aspiring
or retiring martial arts hero
yeah i feel like people are responding
positively to this
like the monsters look cool every i had
some looking at the likes and dislikes
people
seem to be having a a positive time with
it but it seems like it doesn't have too
many hurdles to clear and i do think
that while it is easy to get jaded about
great effects the effects look great it
looks fun but at the same time for as
much
as much visual palette as they've thrown
here it doesn't seem that unique of a
movie
yeah i know actually which is kind of
surprising i can't tell
any defining flavor other than okay they
got monsters in the desert like
and a bunch of stock bad asses i guess
and if this wasn't the pandemic
would it be coming out in january
instead of december
yes absolutely this looks like a january
movie
all right guys well monster hunter did
you like the trailer it looks fun
looks cheesy look uh i don't know
i feel like should i i don't even know
what i want all right
sorry if i offended you with my opinion
fun
and cool i think if you like this video
hit the like button subscribe hit that
notification bell leave your thoughts
down below last but not least
i'd like to shout out to delia
chamberlain today you're dealing with
all kinds of
monsters of ideological monsters you
gotta deal with you're
in your own hometown all the time and
you're hunting them down with the right
kind of knowledge of information and i'm
proud of you for doing that she
is a manager for a schmodown podcast
and she asked if uh we can be on it for
an interview
i said yeah john do you want to be on it
i haven't run it by you yet
absolutely i refuse no of course yeah
so yes lovely surprise we will be on
that interview
so thank you adelia for being you
anything
you want as long as we can make the time
for it
then yes absolutely around this schedule
i love you
you're the mia jovovich of our patreon
absolutely i hope
that's a compliment i hope you do